as you know for the second year in a row
all the acting nominees are white but
worse than that if you're a black actor
just getting the opportunity to be in a
movie can be a struggle let's take a
look what are you doing sorry your joy I
enjoy
it's not rocket science it's a mom just
say something all right
he's like so brave uh my Donatella to
say something about the mom talk about
the mom say something maybe one day
they'll make a movie about a skinny
white lady who invented him up course a
black girl would have to invent the cure
to cancer before they even give her a TV
movie oh my god but hey I'm not mad cuz
I know how to play the game joy my agent
called you twice
then I called you 16 times you should
have called me back
look at me a black Bess bein stylish on
a Danish girl I'm here
Oh is he still up there oh yeah
should we get him yeah you should get me
don't worry black astronaut we will
it'll cost $2,500 oh that's a lot can we
just leave him up there
Oh guys I can hear you I'm right here
hi yeah might be a PR problems I'll tell
you what's a PR problem spending twenty
five hundred white dollars to say one
black astronaut will all be out of jobs
why duh yeah but I don't I don't really
see a black astronaut to see a black
astronaut newer I don't see my caste
remit no black astronauts here alright
you want to get lunch oh yeah nothing
far everything since to see told you
they won't gonna bring you back hey ma P
could you help me kiss my ass